And lastly we've got the hierarchical LOD or hierarchical level of detail where
Unreal can then make some affordances based on how you batch your assets
together and if you want to change the level of detail based on a certain
cluster. So if you check out the hierarchical LOD in the outliner here
and you can see the hierarchical LOD window, do you want to automatically do
this? That's on the top right LOD auto and you can also then generate a single
cluster for a level. So depending on the actor and the level of detail that actor
has, again you can change the level of detail in the static mesh editor if you
want but also you can kind of cluster these meshes together and
say okay here's the original triangle count of this specific actor it had you
know 38,000 triangles and we've actually reduced the number of triangles by
nearly a hundred percent and so it's a really good optimization especially
when you're trying to hit a wide range of platforms using hierarchical
level of detail can give you massive control over changing those sliders in
terms of trying to reduce the number of triangles being rendered on the
screen especially if you're trying to scale across maybe PC console and
mobile for example so definitely worth checking out the hierarchical level of
detail tool